all right
good evening residents members and
officers welcome to the overview and
scrutiny Committee of the 1st of
February 2023
before we start the meeting I would like
to read out the emergency evacuation
announcement
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm activates please leave the
building in an orderly fashion via your
nearest fire exit
two fire exits through the partition
doors are currently not in use
due to ongoing Works therefore the fire
exits are through the main doors of the
hall or the store room adjacent to the
stage
the fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance of the
building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any of your belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
would you please switch off mobiles or
turn them to silent
toilets and hand washing facilities are
available in the foyer
I'd note that there are members of the
public who wish to photograph and video
so thank you you're in the in the
correct place thank you
um
members there's a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording
these are all switched on and ready for
use so you do not need to adjust them
please make sure that the microphone is
close to your mouth before speaking and
please speak clearly
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution I
will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations and we'll
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
so moving on to agenda item one
apologies for absence we've received
apologies from absence for councilor
James Gooding and councilor Mike
Wilkinson are there any other apologies
for absence
okay
okay thank you councilor Mrs Gadsden
a gender item two substitute members
members we have councilor Mike Webb
substituting for councilor James Gooding
agenda item three non-members attending
we have councilor Danielle Belton
councilor Ian Ward councilor Simon
Wootton council Mrs filma Wilson and
councilor Jim Cripps so welcome to
oh sorry and councilor Michael Hoyt how
could I forget
agenda item four minutes of the meeting
held on the 10th of January 2023
are the minutes agreed members
okay thank you those are agreed
agenda item five to receive Declarations
of Interest are there any Declarations
of Interest members
okay no one's indicating thank you
agenda item six we are moving on to
sorry
oh yeah are there any
Declarations of whipping
okay thank you
agenda item six is the
um Mill Hall Event Center outcome of the
community expressions of Interest
process and future operating
costs I'd like to ask Council Ian Ward
the portfolio holder of assets and
investment to make a statement before we
move forward
thank you chairman members of the
committee thank you for inviting us for
this meeting of the overview and
scrutiny committee meeting to discuss
the outcome of the community expression
of Interest process and the future
operating costs pertaining to the Mill
Hall as well as the following item the
community investment plan
the documents you had before you this
evening are the facts and the figures
collated over a period of time that we
consider are required to make the Mill
Hall operational as an ongoing
successful project
if it is not already obvious to some I
would like to make it plain that this
Administration and I as portfolio holder
for assets are committed in intention in
making this Mill Hall a success
we will be looking at all the
opportunities that will inevitably
follow subsequent to yourselves looking
at this high level document and the
information pertaining to it and making
any regimen recommendations as you see
fit that would assist the executive
myself and the officers in achieving a
venue that the residents of Rayleigh and
the district can be truly proud of
at this moment the Mill Hall is open
taking bookings and as an indication of
intent the reception for the council in
Rayleigh uh the reception now will will
be here at the end of this week
as well as the CIB which is in Residence
at this moment
so as you see the repurposing itself
continues to be ongoing but the
documents you have before you will
enable it to go forward into a more
vibrant and exciting future and I'd like
to hand over sorry thank you Council
before you uh do could I just welcome
we've got three visitors tonight who are
going to speak about the process and
we've got Scott Williams and Julie
Salford from the mega Center and also
we've got James Edmonds from the
design cabin welcome to all of you
um you're not here on trial so welcome
and and try and relax thank you so could
I hand over to Phoebe Barnes director of
assets and investment to introduce the
report
thank you chair
um members will be aware that on the
13th of July the decision was made to
open the Mill Hall arts and events
center the building was subsequently
open on the 12th of September
following that decision as well a
community expression of Interest was
started and the report details the
process and all and updates the
committee as to where we are with that
process
and previously the site had been part of
the ADP and therefore it was deemed
mothballed and the operating budgets
were removed from the council's medium
term Financial strategy since then the
decision has been made to take the asset
out of the ADP and it is no longer part
of the ADP therefore this report is
highlighted the information that we know
now around the financials what we
require to build into the council's
medium-term financial strategy to ensure
the building can remain in the interim
operational by the council whilst we
build up that full business case as to
what the future of this building will be
and how it will be operated
um so this report is the start of that
process
um to develop that full business case
around the Mill Hall and happy to take
questions around it all thank you
foreign
members are there any questions
on the vote council Mrs Newport
yeah I have a question it's page 6.6 of
the report and it's 0.9 where the report
makes reference to the building's
condition survey members did request
this at the pre-scrutiny meeting
um chairman can you tell me if we've
received that or where I can find it
we've not received that but I'd ask
Phoebe if you can explain
the nature of that report yep so the
report is a report commissioned
um by a to a rick surveyor who they have
produced that kind of granular
operational data around what the asset
needs in order to remain compliant is
one area and also open the report does
summarize the quantities and what needs
to be done
um it's not that it it's the request
came in and it's it's a large report to
then try and circulate as as a document
it's not that it's can't be circulated
and happily circulated after this
meeting that's just requested it before
the meeting
I wasn't made aware of that only until
earlier today so that's why it didn't
come but as the report highlights the
report highlights all the key areas
around that report that officers are
working too it's a is produced by
rexifier it's
um addresses all the risk areas
um
analyzes them from risk one down to the
kind of low risks to the council so
we've prioritized them over the the 15
years as to what needs to be done
relatively quickly and what can be done
at a later date profiling the investment
required in the building
is sorry can I follow up on on your
behalf again
can members have a soft copy made
available of that report
yeah it can be made available it's just
we just didn't have the time from when I
got the notification it's that is all
um the report was part of the AI process
as well that did go out so members can
have that have that okay thank you
councilor Mr Newport
thank you chairman
um thank you Phoebe for your response
um I found that by a lot to take in as
you were just um verbally explaining
those reasons
I'm extremely disappointed that we
haven't received that information in a
timely fashion as we did request it at
the pre-meeting and that is the purpose
of a pre-meeting so chairman I hope you
will take that away
um I've got a question that I'd like to
put to the chair
um to start with and that is today he
sent us an email
um
stating that
today we're fortunate to have three
Witnesses here and I thank you all for
attending and giving up your own time to
come into the overview and scrutiny
committee meeting
um and he has told us in this email and
I I'm going to ask him if this email
still stands tonight is that
um all questions to our Witnesses should
be put to him and he will ask those
questions to make sure that we as
members don't accidentally stray into
commercially sensitive or embarrassing
areas for the visitors
I find this extremely disappointing and
I do not feel that that upholds the
known and principles of openness
transparency and respect and respect for
the work of the committee
and I think that
I would like to know if that email that
we've received today still stands now as
when I received his email I immediately
phoned the chairman and asked him to go
back to officers
and state that I was very unhappy with
that process
so if the chairman could answer that
that would be great yep that does that
and um can I ask Mr huntkin just for the
considered advice on that please
I think this has been put in place
because of the fact that um we have our
preferred Partners here today and we're
still actually going through the process
of uh making sure that we have a
business case of which they are actually
helping to develop as well
so I think when you're putting um
questions to officers and members and
you have a report in front of you I
think that's a very very straightforward
when you're actually dealing with uh
third parties here who haven't really
been part of the process uh in its
entirety when there's a need just to
make sure that uh we we are focusing on
on the right areas
Council Newport yep
um chairman or on that basis that the
email still stands I would like to move
to defer today's
um this item on the agenda so that we
can resolve these outstanding issues
with the witnesses and that this Council
then can take forward open scrutiny on
this item
yeah
Council Mr Mason thank you okay members
so
yep
thank you thank you chairman
um I also received the email no surprise
there
and I took a look at to government
guidance and in particular
a document entitled
statutory guidance on overviewing
scrutiny in local and combined
authorities
it was dated 2019 and surprise surprise
the full word came from
a Mr sunac when he was Minister of
Housing at dcog
given his other statements about
propriety and so forth I decided to take
a good look at this document because it
must have got his seal of proprietary
assurance
I couldn't find anything in there which
might require us to take this course of
action
and in fact looking at the document as a
whole
I conclude it that actually it was
incongruous with the ethics and approach
of the whole document which is statutory
guidance thank you chairman
so that is the reason why I've seconded
it okay thank you so the motion then
would you repeat the motion please
cancel Newport
yes uh chairman I am proposed to defer
this item to resolve the issues that
that um has been pointed out in this
email with the witnesses and have the
account and that the council
can conduct uh the scrutiny work with
open scrutiny
so members we have the motion so those
in favor of the motion would you please
indicate by raising your hand
okay
okay those against
those abstaining
okay
so that motion is carried so this item
will be deferred until the next meeting
can I apologize to the um our guests
food
unfortunately unfortunately no the
motion's been made now so it's closer
running professional businesses in our
time and actually I've got a record here
of over 15 opportunities when you've
done exactly the same as you've done to
us tonight and that is actually quite
disrespectful to my colleague and my
colleague that's all I'm going to say
yeah it's a family funeral tomorrow
should have gone today with my wife said
no
as chairman all I can do is apologize
yeah Vice chairs
hey excuse me to our guests we were
unaware of that motion coming forward so
we do apologize thank you
yeah
so just to be clear
the motion that was put was relating
purely to the witnesses not to the
report overall
to not know sorry not that item item
item six is that
right so the whole item okay yeah
okay moving on to item seven
um
Phoebe Barnes director of assets and
investment will introduce the report
Phoebe
thank you chair
um on the 25th of March 2022 Rochford
District Council agreed to enter into a
deed variation with Sanctuary
um Sanctuary did pay the council a
million pounds of funding and to support
ongoing Place shaping work across the
district this fund was provided to
council to use in relation to the
community investment programs projects
and initiatives
the money is being held by the Council
of ring events Reserve to be spent in
accordance with the community investment
plan objectives this report outlines
what them objectives are and looks at
how we can draw down on that funding to
progressing objectives for that money so
high level objectives are that we want
any money spent from that Reserve to
promote and deliver regenerational
opportunities that support our residents
businesses and visitors and provide a
positive impact on their lives to
support and develop the sorry to support
the development of sustainable homes and
communities while prioritizing those
residents with the greatest needs and to
promote and support opportunities that
focus on improving the health and
well-being of our residents
um the report does then go into looking
at
allocating Financial values to them
proposals and their majesties up to that
value it's not a full amount that will
be spent it's a value upset value to be
able to draw that down as officers to
deliver them objectives for that plan
and the purpose as well we're looking at
proposing objectives that kind of
regenerate money so we are putting kind
of money back into the council's general
fund and supporting the financial
sustainability of the general fund going
forward I think you're happy to take any
questions on that as well members are
there any questions
Council Mason
thank you Jim I find myself a little
confused and may I may I ask these
questions in an open and transparent way
last last evening
um
Mr Willis very kindly hosted a zoom
discussion a briefing on the budget as
approved the content was approved by the
leader
and within that there was a sum put
aside
for Mill Hall
is that the same I I I'll try not to
give information that shouldn't be in
public so I've referred to it generally
but is there any any coincidence Mr
Willis because you're here
between that figure you spoke about last
evening
and the figure we now see in this report
thank you chair
um it's coincidental I can say the
figure in this report is capital in
nature to cowgirl works the figure that
councilor Mason's referring to was in
respect of ongoing costs of running
management and maintenance of the
building so it was coincidental that it
was a similar almost same sum
does that answer the question councilman
come back on that chair yep
um
I'm also concerned that
around the issue of Mill Hall
no one's been able to
advise me what the position is with
regard to the current
contract and or lease
and the requirement to
refurbish Mill Hall
to the same condition
as it might be released from contract
or lease
I actually councilor Mason that was
actually in the previous report
there was there was a
which we've we've now deferred I believe
about the costs can you be specific
where in the in item seven that you're
referring so please purely the fact
we're talking about Mill Hall chairman I
don't differentiate in the council
between reports that um aren't subject
to exempt
um they cross fertilize they give cross
information between each other
and if it refers to spending on Mill
Hall I'm I believe in scrutiny I'm
entitled to ask a question that's
coincidental as well
so specifically we're looking at item
seven at the moment specifically which
is the figure that you're referring to
in the report please
um I will I will refer to item paragraph
4.3 on page 7.3
sorry Phoebe yeah thank you chair
um so you are correct
um the purpose of this report is to
actually draw down the funding in order
to
fund the costs that we were allocating
to Mill Hall in item six so it is
capital expenditure on the Mill Hall
building and the community investment
plan which is a ring fenced earmark
Reserve will be drawn down to fund that
budget request and this proposal is
asking for that drawdown from that
Reserve to fund the budget request is
outlined in Liverpool that was the
united six
comes to Mason
Council Newport
foreign
thank you chairman
um Phoebe
if I may through you chair
I'm a bit thick with numbers so bear
with me
I think what maybe councilor Mason
saying and you can correct me but I want
to understand this
if you want to spend 185 000 pounds
how do you know you need to spend 185
000 pounds if we don't know
what works are going to be done to
reinstate
when we release the lease and that's the
way I'm looking at it so
if they come back and they put it in
perfectly shiny new order do we still
need to spend that 185 000
that's what I don't understand I may be
on a different track to council Mason
but
could you clarify for me so regarding
the lease around the mill hall building
and this was varied in December 2020
regarding the impacts of kovic 19 but
then also it
um
around the Leisure science but this
building was taken out of that lease
therefore the lease surrounding it
coming back to a set standard was no
longer in that because the decision was
that this building was in the ADP and
therefore it was mothballed what then
happened is once the Mill Hall was
reopened we entered into negotiations
with Fusion around a contract for them
to carry out just the repairs and
maintenance on this building therefore
the the money that's being request is to
be drawn down from the community
um investment plan Reserve is money that
we've allocated from the stock condition
server that was carried out and this is
kind of the risk areas that are priority
um therefore this is why we're putting
it into this to fund them risk areas and
to give some longevity to the asset and
make it compliant
instantly rather than it becoming a
non-compliant asset there's no budgets
to at the moment hence why we're asking
for this fund to be drawn down to give
the budget
because people
thanks Phoebe so essentially you're
saying that it's been waived through the
variation in the lease
is that what you're saying yeah because
the decision was to mothball it
therefore it was going to be developed
therefore it was
it didn't need it wasn't being returned
to a set standard I would say because
the decision at that time was that it
was going to not be operational so the
negotiations with Fusion was that they
could invest that money elsewhere which
they have done in the Leisure centers
um but obviously now the asset has
reopened and therefore we need to do
some work to it
foreign
any other questions
yeah counselor webbed
thank you chairman
um I'd just like to ask a question
around 1.2 paragraph three uh the 75 000
pounds that's been set aside to deliver
a comprehensive community and
stakeholder engagement process that's
mentioned again under 4.7 that the
council will commission professional
expertise to lead a community engagement
process about 12 months ago I was
involved in the welcome back fund and I
believe that there was a very
comprehensive process that took place at
that point linking with stakeholders and
an excellent piece of work was carried
out which the council now has I do hope
we're not going to be duplicating that
work that took place 12 months ago
please thank you
no I confirmed that we would uh we won't
be doing that and the purpose of the
money yes is to engage external support
but it's kind of a gold-plated
engagement process
um that we have um that has also been
used um from under the one team
partnership at Brentwood with them
bringing their Housing Development sites
through to kind of a planning stage
um we're looking at potentially using
the same supplier who've done a lot of
Engagement with residents tenants
businesses and people that are all
together to to the point where actually
we had residents speak at the Planning
Commission in favor of what we was doing
um it's again it's a money up to and the
detail of that strategy and that
engagement needs to come back but it's
just allowing us to progress to that
that stage of it I was again not saying
we're going to spend all that money we
just need some ability to
get to that stage where we can come
forward with what we want to deliver how
we're going to deliver it and then
getting the sign up to to do it and
completely spend that funding
thank you councilor Mrs McPherson sorry
thank you chairman um
I think we've been putting a little bit
of a predicament tonight
um
councilor Mr Mason bought forward a
reason for item six to be deferred with
councilor Newport unfortunately the
information that you quoted councilor
Mason none of us are privy to so
therefore it was quite difficult for us
to have about
um you were quoting him
a paper that
you if you would would like to explain
again what it was that you quoted
um Council Mr Mason I'm just trying to
I'm just trying to set a picture here
because it's very difficult for us now
to be reviewing
item seven based on the fact that we've
had to defer item six
so
um I'm not sure chairman what we should
do with this item I think there's a few
more questions but it is a difficult
predicament that we're in at the moment
can I move for an adjourn a five minute
adjournment because I just want to take
some advice on this so we'll take five
minutes please members
hung upon us if we're knowing that we
could have actually read it and
confirmed that it was relevant that was
that was the idea of adjourned
foreign
members we are ready to restart
okay thanks members
so the the reason I wanted to have the
adjournment was to make sure that
we were clear about the relationship
between item six and item seven so
although item six and item seven are
connected item seven isn't dependent on
item six so we can still go ahead with
looking at item seven and looking at the
recommendations for the executive
Council raise
thank you Jim
item
uh 4.7 we've already been discussing
this to a degree
where we've got the uh the council
commission professional expertise to
lead a community engagement process
part of the concerns that I have with
this is that money will be expended to
that
but one of the things that which is very
important which came out as a working
group was that to realize the full
potential of this place there needed to
be some meaningful market research done
now is that to be included with the
professional expertise that the council
are looking to do under 4.7 on page 7.4
please
thank you so that's
will there be a full marketing research
sorry a marketing exercise including
market research that's yes is that the
question yes that's correct
so the community investment plan is not
solely restricted to Mill Hall the
engagement strategy is around kind of
regeneration
um
opportunities across the whole District
so
there will be an element of Market
Research into it if there is
opportunities around these buildings but
not necessarily because the purpose of
the community investment plan objectives
as I'm highlighting my introduction is
around
promoting delivery generation
opportunities
um development of sustainable homes and
communities and opportunities that focus
on improving the health and well-being
of our residents so
the that purpose of that engagement
strategy is not solely to one asset it's
across the whole district and what the
council kind of owns in its own uh
asset portfolio
yeah it comes right thank you chair
um so am I to understand then that we
are not going to be looking at
meaningful market research for this
building
yeah Council award
yeah councilor FD I mean obviously
oh sorry sorry okay my apologies
um Council leaves
um with regard to item six which has now
been excluded
a lot of the detail in regard to the
question you have asked sits within item
six which has now been excluded so I can
say that a lot of the question that you
have asked will be answered in item six
with regard to this particular item
proposal 2 in regards to the marketing
that is to cover the whole of Rochford
district and other items our assets
within that area thank you
count sorry Council raise I don't not
putting words into your mouth but I mean
that could still be a recommendation
from this committee on onto the report
to the executive yeah the the issue is
obviously the relation between items six
and seven
um the recommendation that I would be
looking at would be that within the
community engagement that we should be
looking at some meaningful market
research for this place
to actually make this
uh a valuable asset rather than one
that's just open
okay have we got that recommendation
well
so can you read that within the
community engagement yep
to engage in meaningful market research
for the Mill Hall
to enable this place to reach its full
potential
okay and what we'll do is if we get any
more recommendations we'll we'll vote on
those at the end
thank you thank you
council Mrs McPherson
thank you chair
um Phoebe on page 7.4
um the last paragraph 4.12.
um could I ask you
um what is the relationship between this
proposal and the emerging local plan
so
um the purpose of the Regeneration
strategy is to look at the asset
portfolio within the whole district
and there will be links between the
current local plan and the emerging
local plan and obviously by bringing
sites from Reba stage zero to Reba stage
two that would all be considered and
then be presented forward so there are
interlinks but specifically for this
it's just to get it to River Stage hero
say so on our own asset portfolio or
looking at the land and options that we
have around the district and bring
them opportunities forward thank you so
um a proposal here that
um the Regeneration strategy is aligned
with the new local plan please chairman
do you have a second
yep
um got one more question please
um uh Phoebe this um is obviously a
considerable amount of money can you
tell me what work is being done to
leverage in
um grants through this funding
so the council always looks at
opportunities to exhaust any grant
funding um having the opportunities of
funding what I would say is the purpose
of spending this money is to look at
sites to look at potential
um homes by bringing it as I said to
State river stage two we can then look
at how we work with homes England who
look to then Grant fund to potential
kind of build and opportunities around
that so but we need to get
to that stage of looking at designs and
assumptions and viabilities around
potential sites getting approval of them
potential sites and then working with
the likes of homes England
around their grant funding process so
officers would always look to
then also looking at if sorry chairman
if you don't mind I'm also looking at
the capital investment in a building
such as this
um how will you be accessing
um grant funding towards that please
it's difficult as a local authority to
get a lot of grant funding compared to
kind of Charity based organizations and
that that but um looking at kind of the
sustainability of the building
environmental sustainability we're
working on that around opportunities and
what central government funding we can
apply for in order to
enhance the environmental sustainability
of this through kind of what options we
have around potentially solar panels
um
heat Source pumps Etc what we can do and
again officers will always look at
opportunities of how we can fund that
but until we know what the outcomes are
it's then difficult to determine what
grant funding pots we are
applicable for
I may make a proposal chairman
um that we as a council look to
partnership work with charitable
organizations and others that are able
to access grants
thank you
any other questions from members
yeah councilor Webb
sorry it's me thanks
thank you chairman can I just check the
governance arrangements please for this
funding put looking at
1.2.3 delegated authority to be given to
the interim director of resources and
the director of assets and investment in
consultation with the leader and the
portfolio holder for strategic planning
assets and the portfolio holder for
finance economy and climate and then
taking you to
uh I can see the lady in the port
hooding and that governance is can we
just check the governance arrangements
please in terms of how this funding will
be agreed going forward thank you okay
uh councilman would you like to take us
through that uh no
[Laughter]
sorry I just finished it's 4.15
um it's the second part of my summary it
is proposed that when any of these funds
are required uh the interim director of
resources and the directive assets and
investment will consult with the lead
and portfolio holder for strategic
planning and assets and the portfolio
holder for finance economy and climate
before our any funds are committed
against these proposals I think we need
a bit more governance around that please
chairman thank you
something
um I think that is a recommendation in
councilweb
unless unless you've actually got
answers to that
I'm looking at the portfolio yeah okay
thank you very much indeed chairman I
mean 4.15 says it is proposed that when
any of these funds are required the
interim director of resources and the
director of assets and investment will
consult with the leader the portfolio
holder for strategic planning and assets
and the portfolio holder for finance
economy and climate before any funds are
committed against the proposals
um I can't see any problem with that
personally and someone thinks
differently thank you
Council hope you want to come back
I just feel it's a very large amount of
money
um for the leader and the two portfolio
holders to have agreement over I feel
more comfortable if there was a
recommendation either to come back to
ons or to come back to Executive for
that final decision rather than just
agreeing how this money will be spent
and particularly like my comments around
the 75 000 pounds going potentially to
Consultants I would like somebody to
have a scrutiny of what that actually
will look like thank you
yeah chairman if if I could just pass
this over as as the portfolio holder for
finance economy and climate has been
mentioned she now wishes to have a word
if she may
yep okay
thank you
um the report outlines a breakdown of
the funds so it's not one million in its
entirety it's broken down into separate
categories and I think actually the
reason for naming two portfolio holders
and the leader was to give it additional
scrutiny as opposed to giving delegated
powers to just one officer and one
portfolio holder which is often the case
because it is a large sum of money but
we aren't talking about 1 million in its
entirety for one potential project it is
broken down in the report which is what
we're looking for recommendations and
approval on because there are multiple
factors and the up to 75 000 pound being
a prime example that needs extreme
scrutiny to see if that needs to be
spent and if it is being spent why and
what are the outcomes expected to be of
that expenditure we don't just want
reports to sit on shelves there needs to
be an objective so I think the reason
there's more portfolios than normal is
to give it extra scrutiny I understand
what um councilor Mike Webb is saying I
think we need to remember that this is
already being broken down into
categories just for consideration
I'm hoping am I switched on now thank
you chair um councilor Belton has
somewhat uh stolen my thunder in terms
of the advice that I was going to give
to the committee
um in terms of governance uh obviously
once uh Assam is agreed by Council in
the budget if it relates to an executive
function the executive then have the
authority to decide how and when that is
spent as councilor Belton has stated
here we're actually giving the
delegation to a number of people to kind
of give that added protection from
having it uh all delegated to a sole
decision maker however that would
equally be fine within the governance
Arrangements the committee could make a
recommendation to alter the people
involved but I think it's also quite
important to remember that these many of
these projects will need to operate at
PACE and so therefore having a
streamlined but robust governance
procedure in place is is quite important
thank you chair okay thanks cancer Raves
thank you chair
um I do see uh where councilor web is
coming from on this and I do hear the
other side of the argument but maybe
what we could do is put a limit
on the actual amount if the amount
exceeds a hundred thousand pounds then
yes it should have more scrutiny I am
also uncomfortable about three people uh
being okay spending up to with 350 000
in some places
so I would suggest that we amend
councilor Webb's recommendation that the
if the amount of sums comes to more than
I'm having suggestions here but I would
say a hundred thousand that it does come
back to either the executive or to uh on
us for a closer look
I think that that actually does dispel
the consideration of some aspects
needing to move that pace if you are
spending more than a hundred thousand
pounds I would I venture to suggest that
that would not be uh something that you
would Commission Now for to happen
tomorrow yeah thank you
thanks counselors I'll take the point
about the limit I think that may be
some way towards cancel the web it's
it's the realistic figure I guess
if I may come back
um yeah my main concern is as we're
saying we're moving at PACE onto trying
to do things
um if we're going to go on anywhere we
can always take it back to Executive if
that is something that is preferred but
I mean realistically we're looking at
moving at some pace and getting things
done and I find it's how can I put it I
can understand the hobbling of you know
we're talking to large sums and I do I
do understand what's being said here but
I think it is important to actually try
to move things forward at PACE because
it is extremely frustrating in trying to
do things and we're constantly going
backwards and forwards now I can
understand the checks and balances that
are required on this governance and I I
understand fully but
um you know I I feel that there is a
need that we need to have some kind of
how can I put Equitable Arrangement that
will allow us to do what we need to do
thank you
as I said I think that if there are any
projects that need to move at speed you
are not going to be seeing moving
projects that are in excess of a hundred
thousand pounds at that much speed that
you're going to need that much speed of
decision
um I I think it's it's a reasonable
thing to suggest that there is a level
which you go beyond and then it must
come back for more scrutiny
and I I don't think that that will
actually hold back progress in my
opinion but um that's up to the uh to
the committee to decide thank you
okay councilor Mr Mason
thank you chairman I um support the
views of councilor Eaves and councilor
Webb I see no reason why there shouldn't
be
consultation there shouldn't be an
opportunity shouldn't be an opportunity
for the executive to get together very
quickly
um can't see any reason why that can't
happen surely a meeting can be summoned
very very quickly and and executed where
it needs to be I also have to observe
that the names of portfolio holders and
the portfolio holders portfolio
portfolios themselves seem to change
quite rapidly these days so that's
another reason for ensuring that it goes
back to a body which is at least fully
constituted all the time known to be the
executive
or overview in scrutiny so I support it
okay thank you so just just to be clear
the recommendation is councilor Webb's
recommendation about governance plus the
100K limit now bearing in mind this
would be a recommendation that would go
to the executive and if they choose to
change to accept that recommendation
they could also choose to change any
threshold as well
okay
as I said I'm open to suggestions as to
the threshold but I think it is wise
that there is a threshold certainly with
the figures that we're talking about
here thank you
thank you any
Council wife
thank you chairman
um I think councilor Ward hit the nail
on the head when he said about checks
and balances I think they do need to be
checked some balances here I think
councilor Reeves is is correct in saying
a realistic figure whether that's a
hundred thousand or slightly higher than
that I'm not sure
um but for me that just seems a sensible
precaution and a good check and balance
to have for this amount of money which
is significant
okay thank you
any other questions
no one's indicating you I've got one if
I may on
um page 7.5 paragraphs 4.15
um it's it's a general question really
but will as part of regeneration will
park some playgrounds form part of that
so obviously the council does have its
own
parks and Open Spaces strategy that he
is working through and has funds
committed to
um with any of these sites in question
that we would be looking at bringing
forward obviously again linking them
into their local plan and any planning
policies we would have to consider open
spaces and Leisure but what Ledger is
provided in them and that would also be
considered
um but yeah as it stands at the moment
there's no this
specific
commitment to that it will be developed
as we go through developing the strategy
further
councilwald
thank you chairman
um for the best of my knowledge the
council already has a five-year plan for
investment in parks and playgrounds this
is an ongoing thing so I mean obviously
we'll be looking to see what they do and
if we can marry anything up with it
with regard to this funding then we will
okay thank you and one final point is
when will the Regeneration strategy for
the district
be published what's your timetable
so the purpose of this report is to get
the funding to get the data and all the
information we need to gather in order
to make a informed meaningful strategy
which starts looking at potentially
allocating sites in our ownership and
what we could do with them so once we
are able to draw down that funding and
are able to get all that information
together then we would look to bring
back a a final strategy for for approval
um I would expect that to be in the
summer to Autumn time I don't want to
put timelines on it because depending on
what recommendations go and how I can
operate
potentially can restrict how what we
deliver in a way but
we will come back with a strategy before
we move anything further okay thank you
Council Mason
thank you chairman I I heard this
question whispered and it hasn't been
actually asked so I'm going to actually
put it Forward
um I I've heard references to we've
we've got to move quickly we've got to
do things quickly we we really need to
move forward with this but I can't find
any dates
or expectations of times and dates in in
the report
I'd really be pleased If Phoebe could
provide us with some scale of time so
that this committee and members
generally can get a feel for what's
likely to be happening
so the purpose of drawing down the
funding as I said is to get to Reba
stage twos on on sites once we look
across the district across the board as
to what is viable what is likely to be
the most viable and do that piece of
work
um and then the purpose of that work
would then be come back with a project
timeline as to how and when we would
deliver
um the proposals and the outlines of the
principles of the community investment
plan
um the report is high level
because we can't get to that granular
detail yet without putting the
resourcing as I said to get the data and
get to the the timelines
um around the options of what we can
deliver on
Twitter can I come back on that um yeah
with a supplemental the supplemental is
to say fine I understand that so is
there an intention to put a project plan
back to ons and do we know when because
we've got a work plan you see and we
like to make sure we don't concertina so
when would you expect to bring that
project plan back please
again depending on how kind of quickly
we can move with getting resources in
place spending on on the delivery I
would like to rely on that project that
project plan would align with the
Regeneration strategy so the
Regeneration which actually would go for
approval alongside that project plan
underneath it that would support it so
again depending on
how quickly we can action
um resources it would look to be summer
autumn time
um as soon as possible really because
there's a lot of opportunities out there
that we can do and we need to start
developing that plan it gives
sustainability to the budget there's
a raft of kind of all other avenues
again linking into the local emerging
plan and that as well so I would like to
move very quickly with it
um to get the information out there for
everyone to again start looking at and
scrutinizing it and giving us
recommendations as to how the district
wants to move forward with this
um
but at this moment in time I can't give
a specific date because I just don't
have that information that that detailed
information yet to then move it forward
can I sort of amplify hopefully what you
what you've been asking
is it I think perhaps members of the
committee might feel more comfortable if
there was a high level indicative plan
so we're not looking at
buttoning down to the third of September
or something like that but just a high
level indicative plan of when this is
going to be and a sort of rolling update
as you firm up on on the different
elements and that would be useful for
committee members I think is that would
that meet your needs Council Mason
okay thank you okay members anyone else
wishing to speak
okay we've got four recommendations and
I'll ask Emily to read each one out in
turn and we're not we'll vote on each
one in turn so Emily please
[Music]
various states of being proposed and or
seconded so I may just have to ask you
to seek a secondary on on three out of
the four so the first recommendation
proposed by councilor Eaves is that the
community engagement exercise should
include meaningful market research to
achieve the best outcome for Mill pool
second day
councilman please and secondary so those
do you want to read it out again please
Emily
the community engagement exercise should
include meaningful market research to
achieve the best outcome for the Mill
Hall
members those in favor of the
recommendation please indicate
thanks members that's unanimous
recommendation number two please Emily
thank you chair this is proposed by
councilor McPherson and it's that the
Regeneration strategy is aligned with
the new local plan we need a second from
the chair
huh
could you read it again just for of
course uh that the Regeneration strategy
is aligned with the new local plan
members those in favor please indicate
okay that's unanimous thank you members
recommendation three please Emily thank
you chair uh this one again proposed by
councilor McPherson that we look to work
in partnership with charitable
organizations and others that are able
to access grants
foreign
so that we uh that we look to work in
partnership with charitable
organizations and others that are able
to access grants members those in favor
please indicate
unanimous thank you and lastly
recommendation four please Emily
thank you chair this one has been
proposed by councilor Webb and seconded
by councilor Eaves and the
recommendation is that the delegated
spending Authority is limited to limited
to 100 000 pounds and any decisions in
excess of this value are referred to the
full executive for decision
members okay ready one more time sorry
the delegated spending Authority is
limited to 100
000 pounds and any decisions in excess
of this value are referred to the full
executive for decision okay and members
those in favor please indicate
any against
it okay thank you that recommendation is
approved thank you members so moving on
to a gender item 8 which is the capital
and treasury management strategy
2023-24 Tim Willis the interim director
of resources will introduce the report
Tim
thank you chair
um this report presents the council's
capital and treasury management strategy
for 2023-24
this is to provide the committee with
the opportunity to come in before
approval at Council
officers use Link
as the expert advisors on Treasury
management matters
one of the key drivers for the council's
treasury management activity is that
Investments are made with a view to
security liquidity and yield in that
order
this means that the council first and
foremost invests in trustworthy and
sound institutions
and secondly is mindful to ensure that
it has sufficient funds or cash
at all times
and then thirdly that it would seek to
maximize Returns on its Investments
one matter I draw members attention to
is that updated Prudential and treasury
management codes have been adopted for
23.24
and one of the indicators that local
authorities need now to publish is the
ratio of financing costs to net revenue
which might attract some attention to
treasury management reports across the
country because it's a new um ratio
as paragraph 6.5 on page 811 shows this
is negative for Rochford
as the council's net financing cost is
actually income
from Investments as there is no
borrowing so that's unusual
as the council has no doubt and with
interest rates relatively High compared
to recent years at least it has enabled
us to project a return on investments in
23-24 of 275
000 pounds as is set out in paragraph 11
18. on page 8 22. this is 250 000 pounds
more than previously budgeted budgeted
so it helps support the delivery of
services next year
unfortunately this report was published
without recommendations for which I
apologize
um they are now on the screen but I'll
read them out anyway
I suppose that the committee resolves
first that the capital and treasury
management strategy statement including
the investment instruments indicators
limits and delegations contained within
the report be noted
that the capital expenditure forecast be
noted that the operational and
authorized limits for external debt as
laid down in the report be noted and
that the committee recommends to council
that the capital and treasury management
strategy for 2324 as set out in this
report be approved thank you chair
thank you any questions from members
cancer Sharp
thank you can you hear me yeah
um just for clarification Tim that
investment return of the 250 000 you
were mentioning was that based on
um funds and uh instruments with a 12
months of maturity
um thank you yes it's based on up to 12
months maturity no more most we we only
invest up to 12 months and no longer on
any of our investments so some of that
would be on the assumption that it'd be
less than 12 months because at any any
one time we'd need to keep available
funds more easily and instantly
available
thank you for that but I have a
supplementary question if I may
um in terms of the commercial
Investments
are there any funds that are used or
accessed to the strictly green funds
well did you say green green funds yes
investing in
green startups
um
all the green initiatives that are going
on at the moment
um part of the I will answer this
although it might not sound like it when
I start answering part of the new codes
requires local authorities to look at
ethical aspects of their Investments and
so we would abide by that because we
abide by the code but what that requires
isn't that
um the council would seek to invest
positively in something like green
startups
um or something that was specifically
around sustainability
but that more more so that it would not
invest in those types of Institutions or
counterparties or organizations or even
countries that would that would damage
the furtherance of environmental
sustainability and green issues so it's
almost the other way around we wouldn't
we wouldn't invest in something that
damaged the planet but we wouldn't seek
out specific Investments that were
specifically green or green startups
thank you for that explanation
um is that likely to change uh the
reason I asked that question is simply
that we have our green credentials as a
council and it just makes sense to me
that that we could contribute
uh by investing in those types of funds
yeah thank you chair
um this is a an issue that many councils
across the country I I know for
first-hand experience have grappled with
because they seek to use what powers
they have in order to further their what
are sometimes corporate objectives
around climate change for example
um and one of the difficulties in using
the treasury management strategy in this
way is is probably twofold in the first
case
um we are
tiny minuscule bosford District Council
in terms of the funds that it has has
available when it comes to where it
places that money it's it's typically
with huge Banks huge counterparties so
we in terms of our powers as an investor
is almost non-existent in terms of the
policies of where we've placed that
money
and
um link to that is the second point
which is
um our primary objective is security so
that's the number one priority when it
comes to Investments and that requires
us to only invest in in
Banks and countries that are that are
deemed to be safe as defined by our
expert advisors and by internationally
recognized credit worthiness agencies so
that would tend to mean that we are very
limited as to where we will place that
money so superimposing a specific
objective no matter how laudable or
otherwise on our investment policy could
potentially undermine those key tenets
of our treasury management strategy
thank you um
Mr chairman I do have one more
supplementary question is that possible
yes of course thank you
um looking through that report which was
voluminous
um
quite heavy going actually to someone
who's not a childhood accountant or a
financial wizard
um but I didn't see any mention of
um an external auditor being involved
was there a reason for that
um perhaps slightly surprisingly
external audit do not routinely as a
matter of their standard order
conduct any in-depth order of Treasury
management activities or other local
Authority they would focus on
transactions related to the financial
accounts so payments our income received
in terms of fees and charges income and
council tax and business rates as well
as all payments to creditors and even
payroll and such like
but what it would tend to do what
external Auditors tend to do in relation
to treasury management is to pose the
question does the council abide by its
own policies the very ones that you have
before you tonight
and if they are satisfied on the basis
of Fairly superficial questioning that
that the council does abide by those and
they are in keeping with existing
Prudential codes then they'll be happy I
think the exception to that is if
through their investigations and audit
into the financial accounts they uncover
certain anomalies or exceptions to the
norm or some red flags when it came to
things like liabilities as then they
would start delving deeper into aspects
of the accounts that would include
treasury management so in in a
in in a typical Council there'll be very
little mentioned in the audit findings
report of the external auditor in
relation to treasury management I think
in the case of Rochford District Council
there's even less likely that there
would be any investigation into the
treasury management by the external
auditor not least because half of
Treasury management doesn't even exist
at Oxford District Council there's only
Investments there's no borrowing so
that's standard is it standard practice
okay thank you
any other members wishing to speak
Council Mason
yeah thank you chairman
um Tim can I ask you to look at table
5.2 on page 8.8 I hope you've got the
same pagination as I've got
could you just
um put some flesh on the bones on
capital expenditure
because it's moving around quite a bit
could you put some flesh on what capital
expenditure is being used for
actually refer to in that table
thank you
thank you chair
um the capital expenditure listed in the
one two three four five years showing
here
um
the 21 2 isn't shown but 22 3 through to
25 6 will be in the budget report
and those eagle-eyed observers would be
able to check whether or not the for
example the four million 424 000 in 2223
for the forecast is the same figure that
appears in the battery report when he's
published in a week or two
um I can tell you but that they may not
exactly balance and that's because this
report was produced a few weeks ago and
the capital program has changed I know
um Can compared to what will be
published in the in the budget report
um so what they should be is
the standard Capital program it'll
include the ADP for example is the
majority part of that but it includes
the purchase of waste vehicles for
example
um some disabled facilities grants so
those types of capital expenditure in
the typical Capital program that you
will see a breakdown of when the budget
comes before Council
chairman tonight yeah so you're saying
that when we are we when we make a
recommendation on this report and in
particular item two that the capital
expenditure forecast be noted that in
fact actually they've moved and changed
um thank you chair
um as noted in 5.3 paragraph 5.3 on page
8.8 the capital expenditure reflected in
the table above the
councilor Mason just referred to is the
draft position before approval by
Council so may change so that was
specifically I put that in to address
the issue that I think the councilor is
is flagging the timing is such that you
approve this treasury management
strategy before you approve the budget
we have to make an assumption about
capital expenditure for the forthcoming
years in the treasury management
strategy
um and then because we need to finance
it but then the numbers can change I
would also make the point in terms of
materiality but
if the if the Figures were significantly
different and they won't be but if they
were significantly different between the
years or in absolute terms
and you were using borrowing to fund
that capital expenditure that would be a
bigger issue because then we'd be
calculating interest on that borrowing
taken out at a certain moment in time
and if that changed in total terms as
well as timing terms that could have
some significant impact or a material
impact on the revenue account
subsequently but we are not borrowing
over the period shown here for any
capital expenditure we're funding it
from receipts from asset sales from the
past or from reserves and we've covered
some of that in the previous items on
this agenda from reserves or from a
revenue contribution or from external
funding like disabled facilities grants
and some bits of section 106 funding so
when you incur the capital expenditure
in respect of all of those means of
funding they are instantly funding
funded there's no long-term consequence
of spending the capital because you're
instantly funding it on a one of places
so if the numbers move a little bit it
has hardly any impact on the overall
financial position of the council in any
case
chairman I just like to say thank you
for that and also to be happily assured
that we aren't going to be borrowing
over the period of this forecast in here
and that will probably be good news to
many many members knowing that there is
uncertainty around the ADP already could
I ask a further question chairman the
further question is of course I'm aware
of
the credit ratings that we abide by
and are giving guidance upon
um but we're in the unusual situation of
having
um pretty poor relations with Russia
rather the the relations are all are
almost conflict if not only political
conflict
um can I be completely assured that we
won't be investing in Russia
and I can give that assurance that we
won't invest in Russia
um and all I'd add to that is that we
would we have criteria below which we
don't invest in a certain country just
as below which we don't invest in
certain Banks or institutions of various
sorts the only exception to though that
hard and fast rule about credit ratings
is the UK itself which may fall below
what we would normally apply to a
country but because it's the UK we think
on the balance of risk is safer than
something comparable in another country
okay I could say chairman that in
September I had different thoughts thank
you very much
I've I've got one if I may on page 8.5
uh paragraph 3.2 the last bullet point
um it's encounters RDC determine its
level of liquidity
is this based on historic data or things
that we've always done or statutory
guidance or benchmarking
uh page 8.5 para 3.2 it's the level of
liquidity
there there is uh chair there is a means
by which we calculate the level of
liquidity indeed it's one of the new
criteria that we have to report on but
in terms of
um in layman's terms or layperson's
terms
um the level of liquidity will be
dictated by our cash flow forecasting so
um the liquidity has been the second
most important aspect of our investment
strategy means that we will look over
the coming months and years work out
when our cash flow is just as we would
in our personal bank accounts goes up
and down and we wouldn't want to get
into an overdrawn position and if we
knew that there was a large payment
coming for
possibly capital expenditure they're
often large items large contract
payments then we would make sure that we
had sufficient liquidity sufficient cash
available in instantly available if
possible and so the key to that is good
Financial Planning and knowing what's on
the horizon that hasn't always been the
case especially during covid when
expenditure and income fluctuated all
over the place and it was really hard to
ensure that you had sufficient liquidity
the positive aspect for
for Rochford is that it's possible to
for you to hold to owe on the side of
safety and hold plenty of cash so that
that is is highly unlikely to arise as
compared to another Authority that
didn't have lots of cash and did have
lots of borrowing where the margins are
that much Slimmer and in those cases
there may even be a need for that local
authority to take out short-term
borrowing to provide the cash to make
the payments which is obviously not
desirable because then you're paying
interest on that and it's not always as
attractive as it would be if it was on a
man more planned planned basis yeah
thank you any
final questions no okay thank you so
we've got the recommendation so
um and we'll take them in we'll take
them in turn so that recommendation one
that the capital and treasury management
strategy statement including the
investment instruments indicators limits
and delegations contained within the
report be noted
are those noted members
so oh yeah sorry so I've from the chair
I'm moving that do I have a seconder
okay so Mrs McPherson so those in favor
of recommendation one
okay thank you members that's unanimous
recommendation number two
that the capital expenditure forecast be
noted and I'll move that from the chair
to have a second
Council Mason thank you
those in favor of the recommendation
please indicate
okay thank you members that's unanimous
recommendation number three that the
operational and authorized limits for
external debt as as laid down in the
report we noted I'll move that from the
chair do I have a second
councilor sharp thank you
those members in favor please indicate
thank you that's unanimous
and finally that we recommend to council
that the capital and treasury management
strategy for
2023-24 as in this report be approved
I'll move that from the chair do I have
a secondary
thank you councilman
we beat your turret Council Mason
members those in favor please indicate
because that's unanimous thank you
members
okay members agenda item nine is the key
documents sorry key decisions document
are there any questions or observations
on the key decisions document
okay
cancel the Newport sorry Council Mr
Newport
thank you chairman
um can I just
ask about the uh key decision
1222 the city fiber exchange lease
um
to agree to lease an allocated piece of
land
we've got details of what that land is
please
Phoebe yeah it's
um a small piece of land adjacent to
Rayleigh Leisure Center which is
obviously in our ownership for them to
put their exchange on it kind of fence
it off
um but
again obviously we've this was due to
going February
um we're working with City fiber at the
minute around
the exact demise square footage and all
that
um at the moment of how big that site
will be but I'm just trying to look it
up my email see if I can get her more
further detail for you
okay Phoebe that was quite vague sorry
because I don't know what the location
of that land is
um and also what sort of sort of noise
would be generated by that was that is
that something that would have to go to
planning is that permitted development
how is that dealt with through the
planning system
um and is that piece of land at the rear
of the Leisure Center
um because there are plans for the
Leisure Center as well in terms of
provision of
football pitches and things like that
yep so looking at the information I have
in front of me
um
and again
apologies
around my explanation
um
I'm still getting Upstate with all our
assets three months into the job but
where the I think the existing
existing skatepark is is where the
proposal is because obviously we are
relocating the skate park
um in that vicinity final location be
determined but it's not where he is and
also the other works around that Center
it doesn't impact on that either we've
made sure of that working with other
colleagues around that piece of work
um
so the proposed site is 12 and a half
meters
by
35 which is the proposed yes efh site
um my understanding is again I've
checked with planning colleagues there's
no planning permission required from it
because of what they are putting on the
site
um again further detail will be
published once we've
worked up the lease agreement there'll
be a kind of a new gate in track
to the site
um as it'll be as I said all fenced off
lighting columns and CCTV but that's
already around there we'll be
disconnected and they will install their
own the site will be set a minimum three
meters away from the building as well
um
so that's the information I have today
on it which I can quickly get up but
further detail will come okay rather
than prolong the agony can we just would
it be possible if that information is
shared with at least the ward councilors
the detail around that because I think
if I other rules the same the planning
rules are the same as a as around 5G
mass and infrastructure is that is that
what we're saying you're saying there's
planting colleagues have said no
planning yes because it's infrastructure
I guess yes but there are there are
certain rules around 5G Mass I want to
know if it's similar yeah no totally
that's fine so would you be able to just
outside of this commission yeah
definitely and obviously we would
consult War members anyway we just we're
just finalizing everything and I'm
concerned that that
the progress of the new skate park the
new skate park should be delivered
before the old ones removed
so I think that that's key in that
decision making could I sorry you
suggested taking it outside the motor
because it is a key decision about the
lease so yeah yeah yeah
I understand you're trying to get it in
but yeah can can I just go back to 822
which is
um the mill arts and events center in
Rayleigh
and if
the risk of not taking the decision is
that the funds to operate and maintain
the asset would be delayed and the
impact on Service delivery but have you
got a scale for the impact on Service
delivery
So currently
um members might be aware that the
existing Leisure team are operating this
building
with with one uh care take under the
fusion
contract facilities manager
um it's not sustainable the staff are
working overtime a lot of hours
um if we if the funding for the staffing
is not a protocol built into it I would
potentially have to reduce the opening
hours of this building because we
couldn't actually safely operate it
okay thank you
any other observations on the key
decisions document
counts raise
thank you chair on the same uh same
topic obviously as we have not been able
to debate the recommendations tonight
what is the effect on this is the key
decision going to be delayed or is it
just going to go ahead without scrutiny
foreign
scrutiny on the 23rd
okay so this is February so we can bring
it to that
um
I'd have to confirm around budget
right okay
says it's fine but yeah we can bring it
back and then obviously you've got the
executive following that but again that
is I suppose a decision around the
executive
okay thank you
okay members moving on to item 10 the
work plan
we've got the um
meeting coming up on the 23rd of
February and I mentioned at the last
meeting that the South Essex parking
partnership will be in attendance
we should be having a report on the
planning processes and procedures
um
what I would say and we will have an
update on the information on uh Gypsies
and travelers but bearing in mind as the
point that feeds just made it might be
that we have to slip in
um
the rework of the report item six from
tonight
first of March we've got the community
safety partnership and as I mentioned
before the police and crime commissioner
will be in attendance along with the
Chief Fire and chief police officers so
we'll have an operational perspective
and the overall strategic perspective
and then finally on April 4th April
we've got the annual report we have got
some flexibility so the reason why we
only have the annual report in April is
just in case anything slips backwards
yeah cancel Newport
thank you chair
um
still extremely disappointed not to see
the cost of living
um scrutiny work on the work plan or in
the items to be scheduled get list
and I've
I'll take it off a little bit I have
been in contact with the portfolio
holder about the information that is
going to the executive and I've asked
for the specific information that you
want to put in to form part of that
report but if you're happy I'll take
that offline with you
okay thank you
yeah
okay I've just had a suggestion from the
vice chair
um which is
just for ease of of management of the
meeting on the 23rd of February we it's
suggested that we move the update of the
Gypsy and travelers uh Community to the
community safety partnership because
they are actually two related topics
that actually makes sense in downtown
nicely thank you any further
points
okay thank you members so that concludes
the meeting at 2107
thank you